there's like a trace amount of good that
New Orlean can do in solving critical
damage to brain or the spinal cord
there's a lot that can be done to
improve quality of life of individuals
and that will be those will be steps
along the way and then ultimately its
intended to address the the risk of the
existential risk associated with at
digital super intelligence like we will
not feel to be smarter than a digital
supercomputer so therefore if you cannot
beat them join them and released we
won't to have that option so you have
hope that your link will be able to be a
kind of connection to allow us to emerge
to ride the wave of the improving AI
systems I think the chances above zero
percent so it's nonzero yeah there's
this chance and that's so what I've seen
dumb and dumber
yes yeah so I'm saying there's a chance
you're saying one in a billion or one in
a million whatever it was the dumb and
dumber you know it went from maybe one a
million to improving maybe it'll be one
in a thousand and then 100 then one in
ten depends on the rate of improvement
of neural link and how fast we were able
to do make progress you know well I've
talked to a few folks here quite
brilliant engineers some I'm excited
it's important that you're like solve
this problem sooner rather than later
because the point at which we have
digital super intelligence that's when
we pass the singularity and and things
become just very uncertain it doesn't
mean that they're necessarily bad or
good for the point which we passed
singularity things become extremely
unstable so we want to have a human
brain interface before the singularity
or at least not long after it to
minimize existential risk for Humanity
and consciousness as we know it
you